pour avoir le droit de porter une arme à
feu en public dans l'état de new york un
citoyen devait démontrer qu'il avait une
raison valable de croire qu'il faisait
face à une menace concrète ou qu'il
était en grand danger or dans une
décision rendue à 6 contre 3 la cour
suprême des etats-unis à des critiques
cette loi viole la constitution
le juge warren stormers qui a rédigé la
décision de la majorité écrit le
deuxième est le 14e amendement de la
constitution protège le droit d'un
individu d'avoir en sa possession une
arme à feu pour se défendre dans les
lieux publics
la vice-présidente américaine affirme
que le président ait donné elles sont
profondément inquiets et troublée
élaboré deux phases
cela va à l'encontre du bon sens et de
la constitution des états unis affirme
qu'à ma harris le maire de new york
parle d'une cour suprême déconnectés de
la réalité
nous ne pouvons pas permettre que new
york devienne un far-west dit il la
gouverneur démocrate de l'état ne cache
pas sa colère je sais c'est chez nous on
se raccroche et cette décision est non
seulement irresponsables mais
répréhensible affirme qu'à fille coco
n'est pas ce que veulent les new yorkais
clairement nous sommes face à une cour
suprême militants de droite quoique et
angie lybrand sénatrice démocrate de
l'état de new york
c'est dangereux si cette new-yorkaise
l'eau avec aucun autre pays ne fait ça
avec celle ci ça n'a aucun sens d'autres
comme ceux sénateurs républicains
parlent d'une grande victoire
ailleurs au pays cinq autres états et le
district de columbia imposer aussi des
restrictions discrétionnaire sur le port
d'armes en public cette décision tombe à
un moment où une majorité d'américains
réclame plus grand contrôle des armes à
feu et que les sénateurs démocrates et
républicains 100 ans pour adopter une
loi restreignant l'accès aux armes une
première en presque trente ans et qui
malgré tout ne mettra pas fin au débat
ici valérie michaela bayne radio-canada
washington